when you saw gucci and jeezy bury the
hatchet of their verses
uh did that what what did you think of
that because i think that that that was
something that
a lot of people were critical of you
know personally my my
opinion was it's a great example to show
people they can move past some crazy
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
yeah i see like that's that's that's
i say they both grown
i think both of them got kids and [ __ ]
so they handled it
like man you know what i'm saying
[Music]
jeezy how did it like how he was
supposed to because
i ain't gonna lie see i'm still young
he couldn't perform that song in my face
it's just out of respect though like
you don't who killed my homeboy you made
a route about it any performing in my
face
after we talked about squashing the [ __ ]
after we doing this hell nah
something would have had to happen but
now i like the way they did that though
they came together
squashed that [ __ ] and they rocked i
just think like at the end of the day
like
to be beefing with someone when you're
40. still yeah that's it 45
it's like yo man like you grown like you
said you don't have any kids you know
what i'm saying like
yeah the other thing i wanted to talk to
you about is like
just to try to just you know plant
something in your head is i i noticed
that
you know nowadays unfortunately you know
you know my dog you know shout out to
casanova he's locked up right now
okay um but a lot of
of the authorities are using lyrics and
and music against people
in cases and stuff uh you know are you
i mean is that something you think about
when you put out your music like i'm not
saying you've ever said anything that's
oh but it's like but some of the [ __ ]
that's in these records i'm like
i don't listen to the majority of every
song and how
i don't look into every case like i look
at that [ __ ] for real like
okay boom not even me you're a rapper
right
you rapping by guns you hot your ass in
the car you ride with guns you get
pulled over that just you're a product
of your firemen
so with me i'm from the house of kitty
with me you know i'm from the most smart
i often have somebody that got a they
registered
what i'm saying i ain't gonna go crash
out if you know like
you know what i'm saying what you doing
out here you doing wrong you should
protect yourself bro like
the way you don't have to just go crash
out cause i'm at the point of my career
bro
i got a lot to lose right now bro like
100 i don't i don't got time to be
sitting in those
cellar you know great y'all my mama
depending on me to pay bills and
i'll type all this [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying so i ain't gonna just do no
out off the wall dumb [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying i'm past that no not
the old me the 2015 yeah yeah let's do
this
like all right let's go rock eye but no
i mean yeah i'm chilling
you know well listen man you seem like a
real smart dude and i feel like you know
you got a bright future ahead of you i
just i just you know for
for what it's worth man if i let me be
the old head
yeah yeah i'm [ __ ] with you bro try
to you know talk some senses you